that so I had this idea where I want to
do vlog with a full crew okay I think
him an audio guy like a first assistant
camera I want to get actor to analog ad
okay and then I want cash to film us
going around to like places you know
will be like annoying to anyone that's
gonna vlog but the goal is to get kicked
out of places and then when they kick us
out I want the ad to fly in and go so
that's a great idea that is a really
good idea thanks - and so the vlog will
be all from cash is his camera yeah okay
yeah but we'll cut to the cinematics
occasionally when you're gonna shoot it
with like an REO yeah and then we want
to put it on like a [ __ ] easy rig and
be really funny to put it on like a
gravity like mount so like it can be
steady we can get like a lot of funny
[ __ ] it's got to be just like you eating
lunch and [ __ ] yeah that's all it's like
one day I'd like go to the Grove yeah
I'd be like and just go to like H&M or
something
[Laughter]
all right guys what's up so we're here
at the Grove in LA is probably no I love
black hood yes and I really wanted
another one so I come here is like cut
not loud enough more in everyone more
energy please another thing that we're
saying was a what to kick it off like I
would go stand like right in front of
the camera and be like what's up guys
you know I want to did it I really want
to do things special for this vlog and
then the camera would back out or like
the frame would back out and then the
first assistant camera would fly in and
he'd be like scene 47 alpha Baker 1 take
1 mark a camera be cameras C marker D
marker and just so many cameras like
it's like TV it's just like 10 key
marker marker X 1 X 2 a 7
Chloe is that Dustin club is 2012
these are Dustin oh these are just all
in my bag on my wrists all of us